in Napoleon's Egypt University of
Michigan professor Juan Cole recounts
Napoleon's attempt to acquire Egypt as a
French colony he explains that though
the initial invasion was successful over
time the Egyptians formed a resistance
that depleted French control next he
argues that the United States is making
the same mistakes in Iraq from the New
America Foundation in Washington DC this
is an hour ten minutes ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for
joining us today I can have your
attention
my name is Steve Clemens I direct the
foreign policy programs here at the New
America Foundation any folks in the back
please come up and take a seat we're
gonna have a fun afternoon we've got one
of I think the most informed and
thoughtful commentators in the Middle
East here with us today I've been
fortunate to have had mostly a virtual
relationship with Juan Cole through
blogging and email but we become buddies
of a sort whenever I find out that he's
coming through Washington very
frequently to help our government have
you know better sensors and benchmarks
on what's going on over there and I'm I
think this was probably not always the
case our government was not always
interested in listening the people who
knew a lot what was going on but tied
seems to be turning I also want to say
welcome to our c-span audience it's with
us today my good friend Bill bridges
came in bill just walk right in and come
up and take the front seat you get the
legroom let me tell you a few things
about one coal one I know best through
his blog informed comment and all of you
can go to Juan Cole comm and read what I
think is one of the premier blogs on
religion history culture of the Middle
East it is an absolutely must read for
anyone who is regularly commenting I was
just on the blog a few moments ago and
was reading just a clip about an Iranian
move into temporary move into the
Kurdish region and chasing some
terrorists there one gathers material
and information from the Arab press and
shares it with all of us and it's it's
material that we just don't get here in
either the English language press here
in the United
States or Britain or others and I think
that it plays just a phenomenal role in
helping us remain informed he's also a
professor of Middle Eastern and South
Asian history at the University of
Michigan he's the president of a global
Americana Institute he's a regular
column in salon comm and we're here
today to discuss his new book napoleon's
egypt invading the Middle East which
I've already begun and it's mesmerizing
I started 10 years ago 11 years ago an
Institute with Chalmers Johnson called
the Japan Policy Research Institute and
chale and I both kind of gone global
since but I liked Chows comments about
the book and what Chou has said is we
are told at the time of their invasion
of Iraq the top leaders of the United
States did not know anything about the
division within within Islam between
Sunni and Shia or for that matter the
history of Iraq Iran Egypt or the other
key countries of the Middle East
typical chalmers if any American is
interested in catching up the place to
begin is with juan coles napoleon's
egypt the invention of the Middle East a
masterful and beautifully written
account of Western imperialism first
assault on the Islamic world I couldn't
agree more with Chalmers and as I said
in my the beginning one of the things it
does give me some hope now and then is
that Wan does come to Washington is
talking to people of significance in our
intelligence and foreign policy
bureaucracies and is trying to educate
them on what is going on whether they're
listening and implementing anything he
is saying is an entire different subject
perhaps for another day but without
further ado please help me welcome Juan
Cole
[Applause]
well thank you so much Steve for that
warm introduction my gratitude to the
New America Foundation for kindly
sponsoring this event and what I want to
do today is is to talk a little bit
about these what I call bookends of
Western intervention in the Middle East
Bonaparte in Egypt an episode which has
slipped I think largely from public
memory except in some circles in France
and and some circles in Egypt but a very
important benchmark of sorts in in
Western relations with the region and
then the current American misadventure
in Iraq as I researched and wrote this
book in the 1990s primarily and it was
its publication was much delayed because
I got caught up in the events of 9/11
and the Iraq war but as I as I watched
things unfold in the early zeroes I was
often amazed and chills went down my
spine at how eerily resonant many of the
Egyptian events were with what had later
happened in Iraq let's talk first of all
about motives and one of the things
you'll find if you read much about the
French in Egypt in 1798 through 1801 is
that the historians usually admit
puzzlement
why did Bonaparte do this and you can
understand why he invaded Italy you
could understand even maybe it wasn't
wise but you could understand why he
invaded Spain or he invaded Russia but
why did he invade Egypt and so it's a
standard question and many historians
we'll begin their books on this episode
and say well we don't really know why
and then go on and just tell us what
happened but I was struck that we also
have no no idea really why the Bush
administration invaded Iraq and we
supposedly live in a transparent
democracy our leaders are supposed to
inform us as to why they make important
policy and yet I couldn't tell you
exactly what the motives were certainly
they didn't seem to know themselves
because they kept changing their story
about it you know it's almost like a
criminal investigation when you have the
perpetrator under the lights and you say
why did you do such and such and he says
one thing one day and says another thing
the next any policeman will tell you
that that's the verb the one who keeps
changing his story so why why did they
do this we don't know now I have some
theories about why Bonaparte went into
Egypt and let me see if I can also come
up with some ideas about the possible
parallels to the present but one reason
for going into Egypt was was that
Bonaparte had taken Italy Italy at that
time the the northern parts at least
were under the Austrian Empire and the
Austrian Empire and the Prussian Empire
had been very upset about the French
Revolution we forget now how
controversial it was but after all the
Austrian monarchy was related to Marie
Antoinette and they'd rather minded the
way she was treated and and so they
wanted to invade France and get rid of
this heretical movement towards not
having monarchs and so the French
Republic was forced to repost and to to
fight back and then I think got a little
bit of a taste for conquest and I went
on to conquer much of Europe under
Napoleon later on but the first big
event was the invasion of Italy in 1796
and Bonaparte was chosen to lead that
effort and he performed brilliantly he
innovated in the use of artillery
tactics innovated in the use of infantry
in conjunction with artillery and he he
broke the Austrian lines as a number of
important points and he conquered much
of Italy and it turns out that Italy
happens to have be a window on the East
the Venetians and the Italians had long
had very strong trade relations with
Alexandria in Egypt they had very strong
trade relations with Istanbul they had a
long history of intervention in places
like Albania
so once Bonaparte was more or less the
Viceroy of Italy ah his Italian interest
drew him into the lava he began to see
you can't you can't have a prosperous
Italy in this period kind of excuse me
unless you unless you also develop these
trade relations with the East so that's
one then in addition to which Bonaparte
developed a theory that the Ottoman
Empire was decaying was falling apart
and he was very much afraid that it
would decay quickly and if the Ottoman
Empire which was one of the largest
empires in the world at that time and
stretched from what is now the Balkans
uh Turkey into Iraq Syria Egypt North
Africa if this if this Empire fell apart
Bonaparte thought well who's going to
pick up the pieces and he concluded it
would be the British and the Russians
and if the British and the Russians pick
up the pieces of the Ottoman Empire
France Republican France ends up being
this tiny little
place off in West Europe without all
those resources that would come from
dominating the eastern Mediterranean so
in order to forestall
a British and a Russian advance into the
declining Ottoman Empire he would go
ahead and take each up right now and the
only thing wrong with this theory was
that it was a hundred and fifteen years
ahead of its time he was absolutely
right about everything that he said in
this regard but he just was off with
regard to the timing in fact during
World War one what he expected to happen
did happen uh but but he he wanted to
forestall what he saw as Russian and
British inroads into Egypt and this
comes to another reason to invade Egypt
which was the French rivalry with
Britain Britain also minded the French
Revolution despite having a parliament
of its own aside as a hotbed of
radicalism and terrorism and wanted to
strangle the French Republic in its in
its cradle and on the British at one
point occupied the French port of Toulon
they tried to interfere with French
controlled ports on the on the continent
they tried to blockade some of them for
a while they didn't succeed very well in
all of these things but they did have
naval dominance and Bonaparte was in
contact with a French politician named
Tally Hall and Tollett Hall had
developed a theory that the British
might actually end up defeating the
French and why because the British still
had colonies the French at this time
didn't have colonies uh for the most
part they had Martinique a few nice
Caribbean
but but they had they lost Haiti and
there was the revolt of Tucson louvered
to her later on but that kind of event
was already going on in the 1790s
and earlier in what we call in America
the French and Indian War uh that really
was a world war between the French and
British Empire's and and our little
piece of it was only one piece and it
was also fought by the way in India the
French had Madras they had South India
and they were defeated there and Telecom
despite being a supporter of the
revolution a leftist if you will of his
day began thinking that well the old
French monarchy had it right that these
colonies brought all kinds of benefits
and the friend and the British now we're
getting those benefits they were getting
the benefit of Bengal sugar and they had
North America the French had lost Quebec
and so forth and and what the French
really needed was colonies back now tele
long thought that the old way of doing
colonies had been wrong that they were
basically slave colony slave plantations
and he said well that's over with
because the French Convention had
abolished slavery not very effectively
but they passed the resolution and he
thought well let's not do slave
plantations let's let's do Republican
colonies conquer places install
Republican government make it
subordinate to France benefit from the
imports of their romic materials and so
forth and that will help to give us the
kind of advantage that the British have
with their overseas Empire and I called
this in my book an eighteenth-century
form of neoconservatism because he is
harkening back to conservative themes of
colonialism that had been very much
supported by the monarchy in the 1600s
and which had been abandoned in the
course of the Enlightenment most of the
Enlightenment thinkers were deeply
critical not only of slavery but also of
colonialism and one of the reasons for
the abolition of slavery
by the convention in the 1790s was
precisely to forestall any further
colonialism so Bonaparte came under
Talia's intellectual influence in this
regard so all these things came together
the Italian trade interests the fear of
Russian and British penetration of the
Middle East desire to forestall that and
to take it for France instead the
neoconservative theory of neocolonialism
in a French context all of these came
into it and of course there were models
in the continent for for this kind of
thing because the French take Holland
they install the French Republic of
Holland Batavia and they have a mirror
of the French government there and it's
nevertheless subordinate to France the
French military has a lot to say about
what goes on but it's considered a
republic and has French style Republican
laws and so forth so they were going to
do the same thing in Egypt and likewise
I think it's very clear that part of
what Iraq has been about for the Bush
administration is neocolonialism
the British Orientalist
Bernard Lewis said words to the effect
that colonialism in the Middle East done
by Britain and France didn't take it it
went bad you know and I suppose his to
be fair his comparison would be say to
India where the Indians after
independence in 47 managed to have
regular elections for the most part and
there was quite an elitist form of
democracy but nevertheless a kind of
democracy there were multi-party systems
and there was more or less freedom of
the press and so forth that the British
colonial experiment in India took and so
the Indians inherited those anglo-saxon
institutions to some extent as they
moved into modernity they reworked them
for their own purposes but but India
Indian politics looks very familiar
to Western eyes but in the Middle East
after the British and French empires
collapsed there especially after World
War two what you get is military
dictatorships you get the Baath Party
you get proto Stalinist parties you get
dictatorships you get regimes that are
perfectly willing to gas their own
people and so forth so what Louis is
saying is that this thing went very bad
somehow the the institutions of Republic
in France and and of parliamentary
Britain didn't really take in the
aftermath and so it has to be done over
again and the Americans will do it and
this time they'll get it right and
they'll bequeath to Iraq a democratic
polity of which which then will become a
model for the rest of the region
so I hear Louis speaking I hear
tally-hawk in the back of my head it's a
very similar scheme you conquer the
place you rule it militarily you hold
local elections and put local leaders in
you make a western-style Constitution
and so forth and I'm here to tell you it
didn't work then it's not going to work
now and the idea that Louis had of
Vanille colonialism to to repeat the
colonial experimenting and get it right
this time the problem with it is that
it's so abstract I mean there are real
people living in Europe with real
aspirations of their own with their own
histories and ideas and you can't just
walk in and and imagine that they're a
blank slate on which things can be
formed I mean Louis seems to think about
the Middle Easterners that they're Plato
you know we made we made a little
playdough figure it was kind of
malformed so we'll just crush it up and
then we'll redo it and make it nice this
time well do not play though
they they talk back and and the thing
that's so similar between Bonaparte's
Egypt and Bush's Iraq is that they both
occur
at times when Western technological and
and a societal organization and
technology is just not that much more
advanced than what's available to local
people I think there is in the 19th
century a moment lasted maybe 150 years
in which the Europeans had such such
better technology better organization
that they really could dominate a place
like Algeria you had to be willing to
kill a lot of people and be very brutal
and crushed people and for decades on at
a time but it could be done if you
really wanted to do it and people were
in India under the British we're living
in small villages they were mostly
illiterate they weren't very connected
with one another they didn't have the
means of fighting back very effectively
and so it could be done in the 19th and
early 20th century again
the Americans did it in the Philippines
at an estimated cost to 400,000 Filipino
lives by the way and it tells you
something about the callousness and
brutality of the American power elite
that they actually instance the
Philippines as a success story of
American colonialism on the eve of going
into Iraq and and and I'm once said that
if we have to do in Iraq what we did in
the Philippines ie kill four hundred
people then then we should so the
brutality of this is is as important to
note but that period is sort of between
Napoleon's Egypt and our Bonaparte's
Egypt and Bush's Iraq I was exceptional
and it has passed because now people in
the third world mostly literate mostly
urbanized believe it or not they're no
longer living in small villages they've
joined political parties the social
scientists call this social mobilization
and they point out
that social mobilization is an excellent
platform for political mobilization and
so basically they don't have to put up
with being ruled by a distant Metropole
anymore and they don't and they have
their local middle class groups wealthy
groups that have their own local
interests don't want to be subordinated
to policy coming from abroad and who
will help to fund these things and then
of course there's military technology in
an age that c4 can be brought about on
the open market in large amounts in
which roadside bomb is of sophistication
be can be constructed it's very
difficult to fight a guerrilla war under
those circumstances so I think
Bonaparte's Egypt and Bush's Iraq I have
this similarity one at a time before
Western superiority was assured another
at a time after it had passed and and
this is tragic for the Americans because
at least Bonaparte had been right I mean
he his timing as I said was a century
off but he was right about what was
likely to happen in the future and and
his failure in Egypt did not forestall a
relative long term French success in
colonizing Algeria Tunisia and elsewhere
and Indochina but but but Bush tried to
do this at a time when the age of
colonialism had passed and had passed
for very strong sociological reasons and
and this is one of the things that I
think that if if I could retrain
Washington bureaucrats in anything it
would just be to expose them to Karl
Deutsch and and the modern tradition and
Chuck Tilley and the modern tradition of
the sociological study of mobilization
of populations because this is what they
seem not to understand that populations
can mobilize nowadays in very effective
ways and can't just be be crushed easily
why did they go into Iraq well
ah there's a passage in general Wesley
Clark snoo book in which he counts a
conversation with Paul Wolfowitz who
later was Deputy Secretary of Defense at
the time of the Iraq war and this is a
conversation from the early 90s after
the Soviet Union had fallen and willful
which is alleged to have told Clark he
said we've got an hour window Soviet
Union has fallen there is no pure to the
United States it's the sole superpower
words to this event and but that's not
going to last forever
China will come up for instance and will
be blocked again because there were lots
of things that Washington would have
liked to do during the Cold War that it
couldn't do because it knew that the
Soviets would would would repost and now
the Soviets were gone the Russians
weren't interested and the Americans had
a free hand but but Wolfowitz according
to this account thought the free hand
was was not going to last that long
there was there was a temporary window
until China came up and us would be
stymied again in various ways and
Wolfowitz thought it's important to get
rid of what he called these old
Stalinist style regimes like Iraq during
this window now it's a little bit of an
analogy to Telugu and Bonaparte's fear
of being checked in the long term by the
British Navy this is this idea this is
there's a powerful rival looming on the
horizon who eventually might might
interfere with your freedom of movement
in if that interpretation is correct
both of these both of these invasions
deployed a rhetoric of liberation it was
really quite remarkable the degree to
which the the rhetoric sounds alike the
Bonaparte talked about the the Mameluke
government the the vassal slave soldiers
Oh pressing the Egyptian population Bush
talked about the bath redeem in Iraq
oppressing the the Iraqi population and
so both blown apart and Bush posed as
liberators and and the rhetorical device
is well these governments are not
legitimate they're not representative
they are tyrannical and therefore I may
substitute myself for them ah and
implement a western-style Republic hold
elections and so forth and both of them
are appointed a so-called elected
government the the allowi
government in in Iraq was an appointed
government but it allow it was called a
prime minister sort of looked like a
parliamentary government and Bonaparte
appointed a Council of Sunni clerics to
run Egypt and here's another irony
that's true in both cases that these are
enlightenment Republic's the United
States and and and France with strong
secular tendencies however blunted they
may be at the present and and
nevertheless in both Egypt and Iraq
France and in the United States more or
less imposed Islamic Republic's I mean
the Islamic Republic was invented by
Bonaparte and furthered by Bush
Bonaparte appointed the clerics of
al-azhar seminary to run Egypt and bush
I think willy-nilly was pushed into
having these elections in January 2005
the winners of which were the Shiite
fundamentalist parties the Supreme
Council for Islamic Revolution in Iraq I
was I think the primary winner of those
elections led by the cleric Abdul Aziz
and Hakim so and then as soon as they
could fashion a Rakhi
no lobbying maybe passed by Parliament
that contradicts Islamic law they wanted
to put in a special place for the Shiite
clerics of Najaf and so forth and why is
this because these enlightenment
Republic's France and and the United
States lack legitimacy when they go into
the Middle East it's a colonial venture
everybody knows they don't really belong
there so how would you get legitimacy is
by guarding yourself in the legitimacy
of Islam which local leaders in Middle
East have long done so to conclude these
these enterprises have been brutal the
The Lancet study came out last fall
which i think is quite tight suggested
something on the order of six hundred
thousand excess deaths from violence had
occurred in Iraq since spring of 2003
above what you would have expected and
these are not all from war
I mean criminal violence tribal feuding
apparently about a quarter or so of
those deaths owing directly to US
military action it likewise in Egypt
Bonaparte had lots of people killed and
beheaded villages burned there was a
very brutal aspect to the to the
occupation and I think it's very
interesting if you see these french
accounts about the french cutting off
the heads of nine hundred egyptians and
dumping them in the square in Cairo as
an object lesson to scare everybody but
I have to say nine hundred heads would
scare a person that we now associate
beheadings with Islamic terrorism but
Bonaparte in the French Republic of
course were the great be headers
initially those a very modern technique
so both of these experiments I think
have run into this problem of local
people being mobilized
there's a great attrition and and both
of them should be object lessons against
this kind of head-on intervention in the
region thank you very much and you guys
- thank you want know if you can hear me
here I hope you can barely hear myself
the cold I have first of all thank you
for answering the question I post on my
blog at the Washington note which was
how to tie this into a rock which you've
done beautifully let me start with two
questions and and then we'll open up the
floor the first is one of the history
slide which I've been inching I've just
finished the book augustus by Anthony
Everett which you also wrote Cicero if
anyone wants to read a really great book
that does one to to go through and
Everett talks about Rome in Egypt and
Rome of course had conquered Egypt and
before that you're reminded me of
Cleopatra's descending from one of the
generals of Alexander Houghton of the
great ripeness colonies so one way to
the question of why did it work that and
not later but but the bigger question
near Rosen is here nears in the back and
there is a has constant rounds of fame
is a most recent statement was on
Democracy Now on even show the other day
that there is no longer in Iraq and it
makes the question of the difference
with Egypt Egypt is an ancient state
Iraq is an ancient place but not an
ancient state and I'm interested in
whether you could comment on nearest
comments at all and whether or not
there's some fundamental difference in
some places in the Middle East when
you're dealing with in Egypt as opposed
to an Iraq which many people thought was
a patch together assembly that didn't
have the same kind of state structure
and we're now trying to preserve
something as perhaps on preservable
anyway so I'd be interested in those
those two well of course with regard to
Rome and the Byzantine Empire they ruled
Egypt for several hundred years and
again I mean I think there are these
moments in history when an empire has
sufficient technological and
organizational superiority
to impose itself more broadly and that
was true of the Romans and Byzantines
and in Egypt later on of the Muslims uh
who invaded from Arabia in the seventh
century but what I'm suggesting is that
in 21st century conditions Empire direct
Empire becomes really really difficult I
don't say impossible but really really
difficult you know a foreign power can
conquer and and remain forcefully in a
country with an Army of Occupation only
if it's willing really to commit a kind
of genocide because people are mobilized
then they'll fight against it and even
with regard to the to the the Romans in
in Egypt towards the end of course it
was the Byzantine Empire the the Eastern
Roman Empire that ruled Egypt there's
some evidence that the Egyptians really
didn't fight to retain that government
when the Arab Muslims came in because
the Byzantines had tried to impose
eastern orthodoxy as a form of
Christianity in Egypt and the Egyptians
were Coptic they had their own so even
with regard to the Romans towards the
end I think they were weakened by their
social policies with regard to Egypt in
Iraq as as as nations or estates of
course we historians think that the
nation-state is very modern
everybody has their myths about Italy
being ancient and so forth but there was
no Italy before gara baldie quite
frankly and we Americans are not under
these illusions since we we all have to
admit that we have a modern state but
but most most romantic nationalisms try
to locate the state in ancient times
certainly the Egyptian nationalism does
and the Iraqi as well the Iraqi is by
the way think that they were in ancient
state because they locate themselves the
nationalists among them with regard to
the Assyrians and the Babylonians and
indeed there are some ways in which the
Iraqis probably invented the state
they'd been a lot of things probably
writing some kinds of mathematics and
astronomy and and the state but what I
would argue about the contemporary
period is that the Nile is a relatively
slow flowing river and allows for a lot
of riverine Commerce and connectedness
up and down from Aswan to Alexandria and
you can see it in the in the life ways
of people and and the connectedness of
people and that has been true all along
and so Egypt is much more homogeneous
whereas the Tigris and Euphrates are
often quite violent rivers and they are
what give your Mesopotamia Iraq
any kind of unity but they are much more
difficult to navigate in all seasons and
so forth and so you have much more
ethnic diversity so I would locate it a
little bit in geography when we open the
floor right here you see a parallel
between Napoleon's exit from Egypt and
what will probably our be our exit from
Iraq now well no that's a good question
about Napoleon's exit and our exit
napoleon or Bonaparte had several
problems with was staying in Egypt one
was that the British Navy sank much of
his fleet he took this modern beautiful
a fleet that had 12 ships and had 12
ships of the line and so forth and and
Nelson had a similar number and and they
fought and on an early August of 1798
and the French lost that naval battle
and so Bonaparte in his army ended up
being marooned in Egypt they were very
depressed about it and it wasn't clear
how they would ever get back out and
Bonaparte then tried to get out through
Syria but he couldn't get his heavy
artillery to Syria so he couldn't reduce
the old crusader fort that the ottoman
governor was using so he couldn't he
couldn't take Syria so he was blocked
there and so he came back to Cairo he
declared he'd had a great victory in
Syria and the Karl Rove had nothing on
Bonaparte I want to talk so Bonaparte
then slips out of Egypt and goes back to
France in fall of 1799 having convinced
the French newspapers that he has series
of glorious victories in the East and
that he is Frances Savior and and he
uses this as a platform to make a coup
and come to power so here's a screw-up
who had an enormous fiasco and marooned
tens of thousands of French military men
lost the fleet and comes to power to
save France from its incompetent
government on the basis of these
failures because he had parlayed them
into a reputation for glory and success
so it just goes to show you that in in
politics being a failure and a screw-up
is no guarantee that you won't win
Paul sampling what that does be about
okay a couple of comments I think that
you've made a very good parallel between
the connections of Neil of incipient or
mercantile neoconservatives conservatism
with modern neoconservatism the thing
that I think is also true of both of
them that I'm not sure you'd agree is
that I think part of it was that it was
believed that this was also an ideology
that so that I think Napoleon and some
of the neo cons thought that they were
actually bringing liberation a couple
points on your I think you left out one
of the most important reasons for
Napoleon going to Egypt which is to say
in glory being the new Alexander the
speech that he gave at the pyramids all
of that I think that was a major factor
and I'm not sure that that really played
as much now finally you mentioned Halle
Grande as a one two who helped push him
there
to tell Iran who was the most devious
politician in Europe probably if he
urged Napoleon to go there he had at
least half a hope that Napoleon would
die there and rid France of the problem
so I think that may all of these I think
connected to what was going on but I
think your analogies really work quite
well as a framework to the questions
what was was really doing well yeah
actually tell me about proposed this
neo-colonial scheme in a speech to the
National Institute in in summer of 1797
before he got much involved with
Bonaparte and he made it a platform to
become a foreign minister I think so III
think Paul Baba and some of the other
directors went for this plan because
they thought one of heart is dangerous
and this is a way to get him out of
Europe he was kind of a
after Italy you know he kind of became a
power in his own right and he was
intriguing to get up a war with Austria
and he was conducting his own foreign
policy and and people were afraid he
might try to make a coup and of course
they were quite right to be afraid so
there were people who wanted to send him
away but I think that the major reasons
for the expedition were more positive
and I think the other thing we shouldn't
ignore about it was that the the
military in Italy face being demobilized
after its victory so you had all of
these officers who wanted another
opportunity for loot and of course they
looted Italy which is how you get the
Louvre and so they wanted another
opportunity for loot and for advancement
and so forth so the military was a lobby
er for for this and and it was thought
more likely that you would survive it
than if you invaded England and then the
military contractors who had grown up
and who became very close to the
Parliament during the Italian campaign
also thought that this was just a
wonderful idea
and the Marseille merchant class which
had already ties with Alexandria pushed
for it so I think there are social
reasons to do it and the social reasons
also have resonances terrorism thank you
for pointing out that Napoleon was way
ahead of his time the my question is you
talked about this intriguing idea that
Egypt is unified it is a state and Iraq
is not could you as a historian talk
about the dialogues the historical
dialogues in the various major groups
inside Iraq today and what their stories
are and how they project their history
into the future that we are dealing with
this moment well one thing to say is
that most pre-modern places were not
very unified including Egypt which at
the time blown apart went there it was
nominally a province of the Ottoman
Empire and it had a kind of military
caste - slave soldiers called Mamluks
ruling over it but they were always
fighting with each other and there were
tribes and they were tribe
feuds and so forth so there are ways in
which Egypt didn't really hand to gather
together very well either but if you
controlled Cairo and the Nile you really
could control that place more or less
you could get taxes out of it and so
forth with regard to a contemporary Iraq
of course Iraq as a country didn't exist
before World War one again it was three
or sometimes four provinces of the
Ottoman Empire it is true that Basra in
the south and and Mosul in the north
were ruled by the Ottomans through
Baghdad so there was a kind of
administrative unity to the place
because everything went through Baghdad
but in in in contemporary times you've
had a very strong a strong move towards
what sociologists call ethnogenesis
Kurdish national identity has been
reinforced by all of those same things I
mentioned before literacy satellite TV
and the American no-fly zone that was
put in after the Gulf War allowed the
courage to elect their own parliament to
unify their administration to teach
Kurdish in schools so I would say that
this process has gone so far that
Kurdistan in Iraq is more or less an
independent country and it's just not
declared to be so because it would make
everybody outside upset the Iranians and
the Turks and everybody would get upset
about this Baghdad would get upset about
it so they don't say it but they're
giving out visas it's a new Taiwan yeah
so they're giving out visas they're
making oil contracts there they're
wheeling and dealing they're acting like
a state they just don't call it that a
name and and I don't expect Kurdistan to
remain in the Iraqi framework in the
long term on the other hand the Arab
Iraqis despite their Sunni Shiite
differences don't talk like that
for the most part and a lot of them are
very devoted to having an Iraqi identity
and I expect them to be like the
Lebanese in a way you know the Lebanese
fought tooth and nail 75 to to 89 and
then they
somehow made up grudgingly but I I
suspect that Kurdistan will hive off but
that the Arab Iraqis will find a way to
stay together it's not for sure but
that's my expectation since I use near
rosin as a prop near do you want to make
a comment
well I think but I think the business in
the Rockies with Breeland is too serious
literally volunteers
thank you interesting you want to
comment right it's it's not an
implausible scenario I I don't it's not
my number one but but it's certainly
possible situation B with respect to
many fallout yeah well I make this point
towards the if I look you know I mean I
got direct resent with the part there to
be a kind of a juror of the the
Egyptians and to get rid of him from
France and ended up with an emperor of
france and that emperors were not you
know a strong feature of republican
french institutional life but we're very
common in the Middle East and that I
think probably historians have neglected
the degree to which the Egyptian
experience shaped Bonaparte subsequent
career and and and the fate of Europe in
a way the the French hoped to Republican
eyes in Ottoman province and in the
ended up being Ottoman eyes with having
an emperor and and so forth themselves
with and I think that's a danger of
foreign military adventures that it
strengthens the defense contractors or
the war contractors its it creates
mercenaries it strengthens the military
it's it strengthens the the more
authoritarian sectors of society and it
can blow back then all of a sudden when
you're at war winning a war is an
information process it's a propaganda
process as well as a military one which
means that free reporting and free
comment are undesirable from a military
point of view and so
this kind of long-term foreign military
occupation is I think a threat to
republics and it ended the first
Republic and I think it has severely
damaged the Iraqi misadventure and then
the aftermath of September 11th and the
political responses to that in
Washington have severely damaged the
u.s. Republic with regard to basic civil
rights yes mescaline and what can we
learn from what happened in terms of
Napoleon leaving I mean there's one
parallel they lost ships we seem to be
losing our army but if there's something
some way for you to expand on that yeah
well I because a Bonaparte was still
functioning in a bipolar world basically
it was France versus Britain he he was
checked militarily in a way that I don't
expect the United States to be checked
in a in a unipolar world the u.s.
doesn't have a major enemy that can
inflict a major defeat like the Battle
of the Nile was inflicted on the French
so I think that it's much more likely
that the u.s. is just going to face this
steady attrition and you know the danger
is is that the attrition is being spun
as not so bad or is even declining I was
and I just shocked and amazed at how
gullible many of our journalists and
policymakers were general Odierno came
out on July 24th and said US troop
deaths were declining as a result of the
surge in in July well first of all July
wasn't over with on the 24th so how
would he know whether the troop deaths
were going to decline for that month I
mean something big could have happened
late in the month and then when the
month was over it came out that about 80
of our troops had been killed and July
is not a time to fight in Iraq
even the most fanatical insurgent would
think twice about working on a roadside
bomb in July they go on vacation so so
July's if you look at the numbers every
July is 38 US troops killed 43 killed so
we had 80 killed this past July and
general Odierno says that's a sign that
the surge is working you know it just
depends when you when you hear these
numbers be very critical because it
depends on what they say the baseline is
and if you if there are some
fluctuations that are seasonal that they
are misrepresenting and I'm afraid I
think this was a deliberate
misrepresentation they must know there
are some things that are seasonal that
they must represent as a serial and so
there is a what I said before is is that
you know the the truth is the first
casualty of war and I think the American
public now has gotten wise to all of
these things and it isn't so easily
swayed but there was a 10 percent
increase in the number of people who
thought that the surge is working after
Odierno gave that gave that interview
with CNN Wow I will do the best we can
right here
it seems like the US has chosen a kind
of misguided sense of history to follow
into the future in Iraq and as maybe the
photos like effect attempts to sort of
rewrite other words like Vietnam if
there is an example a historical model
or historical story to use this
gentleman's phrasing that we could use
to structure on steps forward and steps
out of or into the rock in the Middle
East relations with well you know I I
figured that the u.s. experience in Iraq
is going to be very much like that of
the British in the 1920s the British had
a big important empire they were
unchallenged at that time but after
World War one the British public was
tired of Wars and they'd lost a lot of
people and they've been impoverished in
some ways and and it when it became
clear that keeping Iraq was just going
to be endless trouble
and the British mainly kept it by
bombing people they innovated bomber
Harris who later conducted the fire
bombings in Germany during World War two
innovated this technique initially in
1920s in Iraq so the Churchill himself
wrote in the early 20s that we should
give the Iraqis 12 months we should give
faisal whom the british had installed as
the ruler 12 months to show a good faith
of the new political class and if they
can't do it we're spending 8 million
pounds a year on this and we should just
get out and that's the Churchill that
all of the neoconservatives keep telling
us we should follow so in this
particular instance they might be right
Connelly I just to relay the questions
first what if you were advising
President Bush what course of action
would you advise him to follow and
second what well you know buddy buddy
but what and secondly what do you
believe the consequences of that would
be positive and negative as I read your
blog I'm never quite sure what exactly
you want us to do well you know this
question of what we should do people are
always asking me that it's a fair
question but I'll tell you a little
little quick anecdote that mocked at us
under the fiery she I radical cleric
formed the math the army in the summer
of 2003 and then by a spring of 2004 it
was engaged in a brutal fighting with
the Marines and muqtada went to grand
ayatollah ali Sistani who's very wise
and old and calm and said to Sistani
look here you know if if you think it's
the best thing if you want me to if you
give me the order I will dissolve the
math the army and Sistani said well you
didn't ask me before you formed it why
are you asking me now this thing is just
not going to end well the American
public's not going to put up with the
long term big occupation of Iraq I
expect most of the troops to be out
sometime in the course of night of 2009
and the structures that have been put in
places near Rosen rightly says are very
unstable and fragile and could easily
fall apart in the aftermath and I think
you know during the period 1975 to 1989
you just didn't want a vacation in
Beirut and Iraq is going to be like that
for a while ultimately these things tend
to subside people find other ways of
ranging themselves and they stop
fighting either they come back together
or they don't you get Yugoslavia
breaking up into six or seven countries
or you get Lebanon and they make a deal
of some sort but I think if there's a
lot of trouble in the region the Saudis
won't like that and they have
lots of money to spread around to try to
get people to calm down and it's
possible that when we are not in charge
other people more wise in the ways of
the region may may take it in hand the
way the Saudis did in Lebanon in 1989
but on the other hand things could go
even worse there could be a proxy war
between Saudi Arabia and Iran I mean we
have kicked off I would say at least a
decade or two of severe instability
instability in the Persian Gulf region
which is the major source of world
hydrocarbons and we have thereby deeply
endangered our energy security and that
of our allies over here bilbrey or
retired foreign service yes just a
couple of parallel parallels eat you do
the one between Napoleon and the current
David all somebody a couple days ago two
parallels between the Vietnam War in the
Iraq war and the reconstruction complete
destruction of Japan and Germany which
shows a total ignorance of history
because those countries both that had
constitutional governments before World
War two I already said that what I
really like to ask you though it o you
in your opinion that's okay too but but
then we deliberating a lot of oh then of
course the responsibility is entirely
that of these rocky government they're
not getting their act together and
that's so we're doing the best we can
but they're not cooperating but my
question really is about al Qaeda al
Qaeda in Iraq that that sort of popped
up a few months ago that now it's all Al
Qaeda's fault and we got to find them
there rather than in Afghanistan or the
Atlantic Ocean or what have you
how important is al Qaeda in Iraq now
well I know does anybody in Iraq have
been Laden's phone number and what is
so-called al Qaeda in Iraq
yeah well Mesopotamia the thing is you
know this al Qaeda business has just
been the there was no al-qaeda in Iraq
before the u.s. went there in fact there
the the US government has released
documents from that from the bath
security police and there's this
wonderful document for
I think it's 2,000 or so in which the
Iraqi secret police are putting out this
all-points bulletin they say a dangerous
radical has entered Iraq his name is Abu
Musab Zarqawi he seems to have links to
the Saudi terrorist bin Laden he's very
dangerous his group is very dangerous
find him and arrest him if you can they
were alarmed about al-qaeda before
before the war and this is the same
secret police that Dick Cheney keeps
telling us put Zarqawi up in a nice
hospital room in Baghdad and ministered
to his illnesses and so forth there's no
evidence for that we have the document
that they were afraid of him which mr.
Cheney has kindly helped to release so
there was no al-qaeda in Iraq and there
were a few Kurds who went off to fight
in Afghanistan against the Soviets and
now I mean there are there are lots of
groups in Iraq
some of them foreign some of them local
who appeal to Islamic fundamentalism -
and and who deploy terror and some of
whom would like people to be very afraid
of them and so they now they announced
that their al-qaeda is likely mean - do
you know to be the boogeyman but they're
apparently only you know 800 to 1,200
foreign fighters in Iraq the the
insurgency is probably a good 60,000 men
so this is a tiny little group and
they're mostly used as cannon fodder and
and and then apparently all the general
petraeus had to do was actually talk to
some tribal sheiks in Al Anbar to get
them just to kill these guys and and the
the Weekly Standard and so forth assures
us that al Qaeda has been taking care of
it of an iron bar so I don't understand
all of this discourse is contradictory
that Dick Cheney says we have to stay in
Iraq to fight al Qaeda at the same time
as he's saying that is all you have to
do is talk to the tribal sheiks and
they'll kill al Qaeda for you well which
is it
and why would we have to stay there if
they'll do it so and and is there really
an al Qaeda there to begin with
you know and again to quote NIR Rosen
who made it just good point says imagine
there was no al-qaeda or that it was
dealt with it doesn't do a thing to
change the political dynamics the
instability or to end the various sets
of civil wars going on but it scared the
hell out well as the administration
wants to using this is propaganda you
know we have been given the propaganda
treatment of here and it's just like
Bonaparte convinced the French that he'd
had these glorious victories in Syria
and Egypt declare himself Emperor well I
thank you Frank smite I want to ask
question with 20/20 hindsight on your
blog as I understand it you've expressed
ambivalent about the 2003 invasion
because of the tyranny of Saddam so I
wonder if you could address what the HW
Bush administration should have done in
91 after the Gulf War when you had the
uprisings number one and number two what
should the second Bush administration W
have done about Saddam if anything this
clearly you've been critical from the
beginning the way this was done but it
seems like maybe you were you were
thinking something should have been done
if it was possible so I want if you
could address that and I realize that's
20/20 but it seems yes no it's a
perfectly legitimate question my
position was that the Genocide
Convention gives the United Nations
Security Council the right to remove a
genocidal government and people ask me
well as Saddam's government genocidal I
said a case could be made so but the
Genocide Convention says that the
complaining government should go to the
Security Council should give the
evidence that the government is
genocidal and that the Security Council
should then vote to remove the offending
government uh and that's not what was
done so that was my position was that
that could be done that would be legal
in the United Nations Charter to which
we were a treaty signatory you're not
allowed just to fall on another country
it has to attack you or there has to be
some Security Council mechanism for for
going against it so in the period before
the war this was the debate people were
having was are there any circumstances
under which such a war would be
legitimate and this was my position that
if it were done this way then it could
be at least legal or legitimate but uh
there's a posting that that's up there
in February in which I said you know in
in Star Wars when they're in that trash
compactor Princess Leia and Harrison
Ford and the others and it suddenly goes
comma and Harrison Ford says I have a
bad feeling about this
I said I feel the same way about this
building war with with with the Iraq
yeah I can show you the passage so I
didn't think it was going to go well and
I said Cheney is under estimating Arab
nationalism and there are all kinds of
reasons for which for which this is
unlikely to go well but if the issue
were are there circumstances under which
it would be legal to do it
those were the circumstances 91 you know
I I think the realists were just right I
mean the the idea that the United States
can now go in and occupy a country and
reshape it is just it's a 19th century
colonial idea the United States has
influence it can it can shape things at
the margins but direct frontal
occupation is is just not something that
that's that's plausible and in these
times Oh knocking out the helicopters in
the Intifada well the the issue is that
George HW Bush went on the radio and
called on the Shiites and and the Iraqi
public in general to rise up and
overthrow Saddam and they did and the
spa's party was overthrown in 16 of 18
provinces in spring of 1991 at which
point the bath military deployed
helicopter gunships against the civilian
crowds and places like Basra and now
Jeff also deployed tanks and very
brutally crushed this uprising it you
know analogy to Hungary in 1956 wouldn't
be so strange and the issue at the time
was that the Iraqi military had signed
as part of the end of the hostilities a
pledge not to use fixed-wing aircraft
but where the helicopter is allowed to
be used and general Schwarzkopf had just
shot them down which
could have done if he had wanted to on
the Bush administration declined to
intervene allowed the revolt to be
crushed it was being led by the Supreme
Council for Islamic Revolution in Iraq
from Tehran on the Saudis and the Turks
weren't very eager to see that that
government come to power so I what I
would say is I think that Bush made a
mistake in going to the Iraqi public and
calling for them to rise up if he wasn't
going to support them but I think the
mistake was in making that call in the
first place because well the
possibilities that after 911 for
dressing the al-qaeda threat as a
military problem but should have been
addressed as a criminal problem such as
you know getting after the mafia in this
country last century
would that have maybe worked well the
question is whether al-qaeda should have
been announced as it's sort of been
addressed as as the criminal problem
rather than a military problem and what
I would say is that it was and that
that's been the only success we've had
over 600 al-qaeda operatives have been
arrested in Pakistan they have been
arrested in conjunction with efforts of
the Pakistani inter-services
intelligence the CIA and the FBI and
they have been tracked down and and and
taken off the streets with excellent
police work and and this is the largest
such victory that the US has had it's
one that you never see noticed in the
press or people write about it actually
James risin tells the story is we got
Western Union to let them put a CI guy
behind the desk so the al Qaeda of
people in Karachi would come to this
Western Union to wire money to the West
to carry out an operation so they would
say well we want to send such and such
amount of money to to this address to
this person in Hamburg or wherever it
was or
in Washington DC and so but they were
actually dealing with a CIA operative
who and slowly you know the people on
the other side of that were busted and
this guy was busted and Rison says that
what the thing the FBI couldn't figure
out was that this went on for like a
year they kept coming to this office to
order it they said you know wouldn't
they figure out like that their old
friends were not around anymore after
they went to that office but then
eventually they figured it out so that's
I mean I think that there have been real
successes from police work al Qaeda is
analogous at least to a criminal
organization and can be busted in the
same ways and that I mean the one thing
I would say about military response is
you had to take care of those 40 Terror
training camps in Afghanistan if you had
left them there they're like the swamps
producing mosquitoes they would just
have come on coming out of there and
getting us so there are people who say
was wrong to go in Afghanistan wrong to
try to overthrow the Taliban unless you
overthrew the Taliban you couldn't get
rid of the training camps so I think
that you know what was done up until
Operation anaconda in early 2002 by the
Bush administration was generally
brilliant I mean a tenant came up with
this idea of using special ops guys to
tool a sir target Taliban targets the
the government was overthrown the
Northern Alliance was put in it was you
know I think really a successful
enterprise and then there was successful
follow up in Pakistan but over time this
emphasis on military occupation you know
who thinks that it's a good idea to keep
2030 thousand US troops in pushed-in
territory for the long term what's the
mission there at what point are the push
tunes going to wake up in the morning
and say yeah that's so interest in Islam
anymore and we don't mind if therefore
increasing our attention
I apologize one last question and it's
only when I'm 30 oh darling
professor cold can you tell us what's
the status of the Christian minority in
Iraq the Turk Commons and they these CDs
who are massacred why is it that these
minorities are not being protected by
Oscars yes so the question is about the
minorities in Iraq who have often been
targets of bombings and and
assassinations and why aren't they being
protected well first of all nobody in
Iraq is being protected
I mean Abdul Aziz Allah came was the the
leader of the major bloc in Parliament
has very nearly been blown up several
times and so there's no security for
anybody the Christians of Iraq or an old
indigenous community and among the older
Christian communities in the region many
of them have been forced to flee to
Syria and Lebanon and ironically enough
are often targeted by the the Salafi or
more fanatical Muslim guerillas as
somehow tied to the West I mean I mean
this is not the Christians of Iraq's
fault that the Americans happen to be
largely Protestant I mean there's not
really any connection between the two
and the errata and and and the Iraqi
Christians as a community were there
before Islam so I mean there's a sense
in which they can be icons of Iraqi
nationalism but they have been
configured by these fanatics as somehow
foreign tinged and so attacks have been
made on them on churches and so forth
they also don't have really good
relations with the Kurds and there have
been tensions there that have
contributed to emigration the the
Turkmen social scientists think there
are about 800,000 of them they're evenly
split more or less between Shiites and
Sunnis they were had a kind of focused
lawn that had become more formal more
tied to to the clerics and so forth and
they're very unhappy that they're likely
to end up being swept into a living
under a
Kurdistan government their Turkmen they
have affinities with Turkey so it's kind
of a mirror image you know that the
Kurds in Turkey are not some of them are
not happy being under Turkish rule the
Turkmen in Iraq are not very happy about
the prospect of being under Kurdistan
rule and this is a this is a problem
geopolitically that could explode you
know if you ever had god forbid a
massacre a big massacre of Turkmen at
the hands of Kurdistan fighters the the
the pressure on the Turkish government
in Ankara from the Turkish public to
intervene to save the Turkmen of
northern Iraq would be enormous so
there's a whole other shoe waiting to
fall up there in the north one thank you
very much thank you we welcome you back
and